if your only priority is to avoid any
quote government shutdown then you're
never going to be willing to use the
leverage that you need to to rein in the
administrative State what leverage do
they have the power of the purse that's
why Madison said it was the most potent
weapon that the people's Representatives
can be armed with because at the end of
the day if the left Florida legislator
deprive me of funding for one of my
agencies I physically can't do anything
with that agency at that point and then
also the law making function stop
delegating decisions to the bureaucracy
the idea that only experts can run
government so let's just give a blanket
grant of authority to the EPA so that
it's constantly legislating things that
have a profound effect on the American
economy and can be interpreted
differently depending on whether you
have a Democrat or Republican
Administration they have ceded the law
making power which is kind of the twin
of the power of the purse in terms of
those are the two functions of Congress
and they don't want to exercise either
of them